die zweite sache über dich reden wollte
ist mein war o2 teampartner fall durch
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer runde super special
ops hier auf dem main black server es in
der beschreibung ich soll eigentlich
ganz zu viel um das gameplay gehen das
geht es bei merck ich nie weil ich das
nicht spielen kann ich bin kacke in
meine haare sind kacke weil wir gestern
feiern waren eventuell hatte das video
auf instagram gesehen
und ich bin jetzt ein bisschen so lazy
sunday was man die wako kurzzeitig spiel
das hat schon den ganzen tag so ein
bisschen und das ist sogar richtig
oktober in rot grün hat eine runde
gewonnen aber jetzt nehme ich den ort
einander den coco war ich zweiter da war
er erst aber eher wieder zweiter naja
mal komische talent peter also es soll
nicht so viel wirklich ums gameplay
gehen sondern einfach um eine sache die
ich sagen wollte und zwar zwei themen
wollte ich ansprechen alisa blöde kuh
die panne der kann auch einfach mal
seine schnauze halten erstellt
denzlingen es soll um zwei themen gehen
und zwar einmal wie ich vorhin schon
gesagt habe internet-sucht mehr oder
weniger ich spiele jetzt schon seit
einer stunde gerade hier dieses hier
dieses wir heißt es hier dieses diesem
game auf hier weil es mir einfach spaß
macht und dann habe ich mir einfach
gedacht jetzt eigentlich die ganze zeit
daran und ich drücke immer so auf
refresh ok kommt noch eine runde weil
ich finde zum beispiel super smash mops
ist einfach mein lieblings spielmodus
habe ich schon selbst auch gesagt
übrigen habe ich wieder meine halle
aufnehmen autofahrerin auf die sonstigen
habe ich blöd man dort war ich einfach
meine leben weg alter mann
ich blöd naja jedenfalls habe ich dann
einfach mal so im internet nachgeschaut
alter was ist eigentlich wenn ich
eventuell irgendwie spielsüchtig wäre
sie kriegt das hat auch mit an damit
dass ich dann sehe das so dass man
einfach nachts bis 5 uhr einen live
stream macht und world of warcraft
spielt also ich könnte das nie aber ich
denke mir dann halt selber immer so bei
mir so was ist eigentlich mit
internetsucht genau gemeint weil
internetsucht es ja nicht gibt ja nicht
nur spiele sucht dass man den ganzen tag
zockt sondern es gibt natürlich auch als
einfach dass man den ganzen tag in
irgendwelchen netzwerken hockt und meint
mit seinen ganzen freunden da den ersten
kommentar bei facebook zu machen und ich
hab einfach beide getötet normalen
herzstich also es gibt nicht nur online
spielsucht sondern halt auch diese
internetsucht habe ich mich dann so ein
bisschen drüber informiert und es gibt
keinen test den ich auch gemacht habe
auf ins minus netz - gehen oder so von
der bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung die machen das glaube ich und
da konnte man einfach zum test machen
das ist irgendwie ich weiß ja diese
kampagne neu ist oder ob man den schon
ich denke den kann man schon sehr lange
machen aber ich habs jetzt halt
irgendwie leute nur durch zufall
entdeckt und wieso treffe ich da nie
diese komischen oper ist tot und da ich
bin nicht letzter das ist schon mal
stark wäre cool wenn sich mein leben so
ein bisschen aufhören könnte weil mein
image wird jetzt hinten erstmal regeln
limited da hinlaufen dem bett leer
bietet machen die wir hinten kämpft
erstmal ohne der weiterhin mein image
oder gewinn
nee nee nee du willst dich nicht mehr
anlegen jedenfalls habe ich diesen test
auf dieser website gemacht die sind ins
netz geben borg bin hochgesprungen und
es kam raus dass nicht gefährdet bin
internet süchtig zu sein ich denke
allerdings dass es bei mir daran liegt
dass ich einfach youtube-videos mache
und dementsprechend im internet sein
muss man muss hier informiert und
recherchieren und auch die sache
irgendwie aufnehmen und so weiter bei
mir kam allerdings am ende raus dass ich
ein wenig gefährdet bin und deswegen
definiert jetzt nichts an meinem
verhalten ändern oder so aber weil ich
halt auch jetzt ich zock ja nicht so
viel und es ist ja auch so bei mir dass
ich halt mache auch noch was mit freuen
und das ist jetzt nicht so dass ich sage
gekommen ich gehe jetzt abends nicht
raus sondern zog hier das und das und
fährt dann noch level 20 millionen und
1000 experian schaffen weil nur dann hat
mein tag einen sinn oder irgendwie so
und da denke ich mir dann halt so rohwer
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
ein halbes herz inhalte ich bin raus ich
wurde dritter
ich bin da schon ein wenig so ja nee ich
mach da nicht mal was mit freuen und
macht dann mal ein tag ein video weil
ich nicht so toll drauf bin oder so und
es ist jetzt auch nicht so also da sind
dann so fragen wie unter anderem jahr
du hast du schon mal schule geschwänzt
um computer zu zocken oder hinten spiel
zu spielen
also ich kann es euch nur raten diesen
test mal zu machen es dauert insgesamt
fünf minuten das 1 18 fragen die man
anklicken muss oder so machen sachen
muss jahr bin ich nie oder mache ich
sehr häufig oder irgendwie sowas ich
nicht übrigens immer darüber skelett ich
habe damit auch nie wirklich viel
gerissen aber ich find's einfach
killerin an seinem image zu spielen kann
also das ganz cool also ich kann euch
als nicht zwingen diesen test zu machen
allerdings es ist jetzt halt auch nicht
so dass deutschland mir zehn millionen
euro dafür gibt dass sich rumschreien da
ist also ich kann ja nicht zwingen aber
es liegt mir selber ein wenig am herzen
dass ihr das einfach so mal für euch
selber entscheidet also ich hab's mal
mitbekommen jetzt dadurch dass ich in
einem fall in china gelesen habe dass da
pärchen 1 40 und 25 jahre alt ich weiß
noch nicht wie man 16 jahre auseinander
sein kann als paare hatten ein kind
hatten ein kind das war vier monate alt
und ist gestorben an unterernährung weil
die eltern die ganze zeit im
internetcafé waren und sich nicht um das
baby at camp da oben schon wieder jemand
oder wie oder ich will mich einige
lieber kemper beschwere mich das sehr
gut gemacht habe die jetzt erst mal
schön mit meinem image da hinten ein
bisschen rum machte schmidt in englisch
nein ich habe selber umgebracht ich
freue mich jedenfalls haben die ihre
tochter vernachlässigt weil sie den
ganzen tag im internet café waren und
irgendwas gezockt haben und
deswegen habe ich mir einfach gedacht
alter junge was geht bei denen die haben
ein kind und vernachlässigen das weil
die ein online spiel zocken möchten uns
oder der auch schon so alt wie ist denn
die prioritätensetzung mit dem bitte das
ist ja sehr sehr krank klar dass man
einfach so was ist denn mit mir selber
was ist denn ich sitze auch relativ viel
vorm pc sagt jetzt einfach mal so aber
ich beschäftige mich dann halt immer mit
youtube oder irgendwelchen sachen für
die uni und bei dem teil
bei dem test kann man dann halt so was
machen wie muss man halt dann so fragen
beantworten ob man so nie dafür
geschehen solle da etwas jeden fall dann
werden halt immer mehr leute
internetsüchtig und ich weiß jetzt
schlecht für rücken und ich weiß
natürlich internet hat auch tolle zeit
man kann mit leuten in kontakt bleiben
aber mir liegt einfach am herzen dass
ihr selber mal diesen test machen schaut
das internet durch die seit weil ich
möchte nicht dass ihr dann irgendwann
auch wie dieser eine da aus japan oder
so der upload drei da drei tagen
durchgezockt wenn man dann an irgendwas
gestorben ist oder so möchte ich nicht
dass das wirklich passiert deswegen ich
meine natürlich ihr könnt auch sagen ich
bin nicht viel vom pc ich hätte es
selber ein ich bin ich unter natürlich
unseren ist in ordnung aber meldet es
dort fünf minuten und den könnte man ja
vielleicht mal machen und das war die
erste wehr dich reden wollte und die
zweite sache über dich reden wollte ist
mein war o2 teampartner und zwar ist ja
wahr o2 planungen was als planung sehen
wollen dann eigentlich zu ende geplant
werden und die letzten dinge jetzt noch
abgestimmt ich glaube die ganze zeit nur
um und tempi mini kaka fällt mir dazu
auf die da oben endet erst mal weg
beraten per stichentscheid peter wolter
ich habe nur noch ein leben als schon
dreimal gestorben wenn man da kaum
kommen kommen nie erwischt ja die sache
jetzt einfach das war o2 ist eigentlich
schon zu ende geplant
es werden nur noch gerade feinheiten
gemacht wie das beispielsweise ist mit
backshop mir ja wenn die drei leute sind
oder die teams warten noch ein bisschen
zurecht zurechtgerückt und noch
vielleicht ein paar andere sachen noch
geschaut wie man das macht und alles
also ein paar das grundprinzip steht
natürlich ich meine das ist eine riesige
zweifel games runde mehr oder weniger
und wenn man die erste folge überlebt
hat dann ist es eigentlich schon mal
ganz gut
also ich möchte da jetzt nicht so viel
verraten sondern euch einfach nur mein
team partner sagen mit dem ich das ganze
mache ich hatte erst überlegt halt mit
chaos zu machen allerdings ist es so
dass das bei war o2 jedes mal werden die
teams gewechselt das heißt nächstes war
also waro drei mehr oder weniger ich bin
tot
ohne scheiß runde weil ich kann ich
erzählen und spielen gleichzeitig jedes
jahr wechseln quasi die teams also
nächstes war könnte ich rein theoretisch
der mitglieder ausmachen
aber ich finde ich ganz cool wenn man
nicht ein eingespieltes team sondern
wirklich mal neuen teampartner
einstellen muss deswegen bin ich ja auch
gerade mal so ein bisschen kämpfen ich
hoffe einfach dass in der ersten folge
nicht direkt sterbe das ist wirklich so
mein ziel ein bisschen direkt auf abwehr
zu gehen irgendwo mich zu verstecken den
weg machen und die sache ist einfach
dass ich euch meinen teampartner
verraten wollte und zwar bin ich in
einem team
ihr könnt einfach mal raten schreibt man
jetzt in die kommentare was er denkt nur
wenig intimen wahrscheinlich die meisten
gucken jetzt gattin oder video weiter
und schreiben den ersten zehn sekunden
kommentare wenn ich es gesagt habe also
ich denke ihr habt es in die kommentare
geschrieben ich bin in einem team mit
epi midcap weil ich hab mir gedacht komm
also ich hab auch ich muss ehrlich sagen
ich hab die konnte relativ spät gelesen
ich bin nicht so oft am pc wie ich das
grad schon gedacht hab ich habe vorhin
gesagt wenn viel am pc das meine ich gar
nicht bin relativ wenig kompliziert
deswegen war ich auch überrascht
gefährdet bin bei dem test aber naja ich
finde den link dazu natürlich gesagt
schon in der beschreibung
es ist jedenfalls so ich bin mit cap in
einem team weil ich mir einfach die
konnte relativ spät gelesen die darauf
macht war wurde für war o2 zu dem
zeitpunkt im kino war ich habe maze
runner geguckt einen film der mir nicht
gefallen hat den fand ich echt ein
bisschen sehr scheiße muss sich einfach
sagen meine normale meinung hat mir dann
max geschrieben jeder echte wahre 2
konnte jeder hat schon partner bei
schmidt behring und max war dann auch
mit rot pilz hat max schon einem video
gesagt dass ein tropisches simon hat ja
auch schon gesagt dass er mit glp ist
patel hat schon gesagt dass er mit
radios oder das ahadi gesagt dass er mit
tadellos oder simon hat sich auf jeden
fall auch gesagt dass die bayern das
sind und ich kenne auf jeden fall schon
nahezu alle teams
es gibt auch schon ein paar twitter
seiten so baron news die komplett
falsche teams gepostet haben die haben
irgendwie so gepostet ja der und er
macht mit dem und dem und wir denken uns
und in der conference lesens dass du
durch sowie 40 leute denken so alter
wieso denkt man sich teams aus das macht
doch keinen sinn das ist das genauso wie
einen nachrichtensender weihnachten
sender sagen würde die usa es mit 30
leuten nach genua eingezogen und hat
zivilisten getötet mit seinen gas- oder
irgendwie sowas und da stimmt einfach
gar nicht also ich weiß das sag ich
nicht so viel von es ruckelt bei mir
extrem ich weiß wie man es liegt der
neue pc kommt irgendwann ist es liegt
auch nicht an mir dass sie gerade am
server weil ich habe 60 fps oder
irgendwie das ist richtig komisch ich
geh mal kurz zurück ins hab jedenfalls
bin ich in einem team mit lp mit cash
und ich habe mir einfach gedacht jetzt
geht gar nichts mehr
ich habe mir einfach gedacht ja komm ich
könnte jetzt rein theoretisch auch mit
dem oder den machen aber mit cap habe
ich beispielsweise lange nicht mehr
gemacht deswegen hab ich kämpfe einfach
mal angeschrieben
daher wollen wir zusammen in einem team
was ist denn los es ruckelt gerade
extrem weil die schon los mit dir
die spammer dezember nochmals sollte die
flüssigkeit zurück
wir sind ergeht ist auch scheißegal ich
würde sagen das war's mit dem video ich
wollte euch wirklich einfach nur kurz
sagen dass ich mich derzeit sehr viel
mit suchtkrankheiten so ein bisschen
nicht beschäftige und befasse ich
studiere auch nichts in die richtung
aber ich fand's einfach ganz
schockierend so was zu lesen dass da
wirklich eltern ihr kind vernachlässigen
nur um ein gott verdammt das
computerspiel zu spielen das war so
krank und deswegen hab ich diesen test
einfach gefunden hab ich mal dazu es in
der beschreibung müsst ihr machen müsst
ihr nicht machen könnte machen wie ihr
wollt und marlboro zwei partien partner
ist p midcap mit ihm zusammen weil ich
mich ans steuer ins abenteuer stürzen
und ich würd sagen das war's mit dem
video wenns euch gefallen hat mal wieder
so ein bisschen old school einfach lava
ein bisschen zocken dann zeigt mit einer
bewertung und schreibt eventuell mal
ihre erfahrungen vielleicht hat ja
jemand von euch schon sucht erfahrung
einfach so ich bin da offen für alles
wird es gern mal lesen mein deckel ist
runtergefallen und